le rouge le rouge noir vert un peu rose
et pas brin banon tu t'es déjà confessé
quand même quand tu étais petit non
jamais jamais chez toi ont pratiqué pas
ça chez moi on n'était ni pratique en y
croyant
ah bon je t'ai jamais qu'on fait c'est
de ta vie tu veux essayer nous c'est
obligé enfin il s'est obligé bon
allons-y battue me suis alors viens avec
moi
es-tu favorable au divorce légalement je
trouve ça bien que ce soit le divorce
autorisé bien sûr mais je trouve ça pas
bien que les gens divorce et à
l'avortement
c'est dommage
c'est dommage qui est des circonstances
où les femmes sont obligées d'avorter
mais il faut bien évidemment le
continuer à faire en sorte que les les
lois qu'ils autorisent soit respectée
partout qu'il qui rendent l'avortement
libre gratuit si le des criminalise que
ces lois soient maintenus ou créés à
l'euthanasie
je prends fallait que chacun puisse
faire son testament et dire non mais
c'est vachement compliqué salles à
partir de quand est-ce qu'on peut
décider qu'un mec souffre trop et que
s'il est inconscient chez moi la
question des routes et priori je m'en
fous à la peine de mort
bah donc même pour les assassins
d'enfants
ça c'est la question vicieuse et obsède
par excellence même pour les assassins
d'enfants
c'est la question piège mais quoi qu'il
arrive une société civilisée peut pas
trancher la tête un individu
quoi qu'il ait fait les tue favorable au
droit de vote pour les immigrés ouais
plus tôt est-ce que tu prends du nom
mais je fais gaffe quand même et je ne
conduis je me comme disait brassens
je me conduis guère plus mal que si
j'avais la foi si tu avais un dernier
message le brouillard sur un dernier
message à donner à ta petite fille
serait quoi je verrai ça y est tu peux
toucher avec à la pêche